okay guys today we're going to talk
about enzymes now what enzymes are is
they're an example of these things
called biological catalysts what a
catalyst is is something which speeds up
the rate of reaction without being used
up itself and all biological means is it
occurs and we find these in living
things so an enzyme I'm just going to
draw a simplistic example of one here an
enzyme has got a structure that we need
to know a little bit about there's a
particular place on the enzyme which is
called the active site this part of the
enzyme is where our substrate molecule
attaches so as we can see here the
shapes kind of this fits into the active
sites of the substrate fits into this
active site on the enzyme we can say
this is why it's called the look and key
theory the lock and key theory because
the substrate acts a little bit like a
key and the active site acts a little
bit like a lock so they're really
specific so that the the active site is
very specific and it can't fit in any
substrate if we had a different
substrate with a different shape we can
see that this substrate would not fit
into this active site and so that's why
it's called the lock and key theory now
enzymes can also undergo changes so if
for example we heat up this enzyme we
heat it up and it gets far too hot it
can actually denature now what
denaturing is is when it gets so hot
that the shape of the active site has
changed it changed so you can see this
is meant to be the exact same enzyme but
this time the active site has changed
shape just to remind you that process is
called denaturing
now if we have the same substrate that
it used to break down before we can see
that this substrate no longer fits into
this active site so therefore our rate
of reaction is going to decrease because
this enzyme can no longer break down
this substrate and so enzymes in the
body work best at around 37 degrees C
because that's that's the body
temperature if it gets too hot so let's
say we heat this work one up to around
50 degrees C that's when it will start
to denature and we will no longer be
able to break down this substrate here
so that's basically what enzymes do they
speed up chemical reactions without
being used up we find them in living
things classic example is in digestion
then breaking down your food the
substrate molecules fit into the active
site which is highly specific so it only
fits in one type of substrate and if we
heat them up too much they denature and
they no longer fit the substrate into
the active site that's the basics of
enzymes